Instagram is a kind of catchall
leadership platform of Social and
entertainment and information right now
attention is the number one asset think
of Instagram more like the way people
thought of the newspaper the magazine
the radio and the television in a
standard 1995 20y old's life meaning for
a 20 to 40 year-old in 1995 the
newspaper a magazine the car radio
station and television all were like a
popery of mix of media assumption to get
them through today Instagram plays a
similar role today people may get some
longer form depth content there people
may get a quick hit headline from an
Instagram image post it's more of a
universal information content creative
portal